trouvez le sapin idéal pour mettre dans
son salon les yvelinois n'échappe pas à
la tradition et ce n'est pas la crise
sanitaire qui va les arrêter
en fait on vient chercher le sapin voilà
puisque ben avec la réouverture des
magasins on en profite et puis on va
faire un petit peu le tour du magasin
pourra les décorations voilà peut-être
un petit peu de un peu de joie en cette
période quoi il y a deux semaines les
commerçants ne savait pas s'il pourrait
vendre ses arbres de noël
c'est donc un soulagement pour eux on
est très content parce qu'on a on a faim
de sapins et on va pouvoir satisfaire
tous nos clients qui sont vraiment en
attente c'est une symbolique de noël qui
est importante et les gens attendaient
des sapins comme juliette elle vient
tous les ans ici acheter son sapin
moi je reste vraiment dans le côté
traditionnel l'épicéa qui est qui sent
bon le sapin le plus vendu reste le
nordmann il a la particularité de garder
ses épines vanessa gênant et son époux
propose aux essarts-le-roi juste à côté
de la n 10 5 variétés différentes
on a pour tous les goûts voilà toutes
les tailles
on essaie de satisfaire un plus grand
nombre de clients après vous avez le
bleu voilà à mettre 50 1 m 75
cette année la montagne là bas beaucoup
qui vont y aller tout un ensemble qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui le sapin représente
comme je vous ai dit la montagne le
plaisir
le bonheur de se dire que c'est des
fêtes de fin d'année qui vont pouvoir
les faire en famille et ils ont voulu
vraiment se faire plaisir sur un beau
sapin noël reste donc plus qu'à les
décors et en 2019 près de 2 foyers sur
dix ont acheté un sapin de noël naturel